le merveilleux chaos de délits prend un
tout autre sens en temps de pandémie
un marché extérieur bondi le port
adéquat du masque pas toujours respectée
ce marchand ne s'en cache pas comme
beaucoup d'indiens il ne respecte plus
les consignes sanitaires kanagawa et
valle del cauca
pas question de se laver fréquemment les
mains il n'a pas peur de l'aco vide
quarante cinq mille nouveaux cas et 275
morts dans la seule journée de mercredi
c'est quatre fois plus qu'il ya à peine
un mois soit depuis la réouverture
presque complète
en inde le transport public a repris et
c'est à nouveau la cohue pour grimper à
bord des autobus et métros bondés les
voyages en avion sont à nouveau permis
les rassemblements politiques et grands
mariages sont fréquents
le docteur chan dry sur la ligne de
front du combat contre l'épidémie
presque chaque jour depuis un an
ils réclament le retour des restrictions
petit revenons à la fermeture des
piscines et cinéma par exemple
pour l'instant seuls des restrictions
régionales sont imposés la ville de
bombay par exemple étaient de nouveau
sous le coup d'un couvre-feu
l'un d'eux se projetaient pourtant dans
l'après qu'ovide pas plus tard qu'au
début février on évoqué l'immunité
collective des études sérologique
concluait que plus de la moitié de la
population avait déjà contracté lakovic
19 jeux spécialistes de la santé
publique se méfiait de cette vision trop
optimistes il mettait le gouvernement en
garde contre le retour précipité à la
vie normale dans le montrent les
intérêts des sommes brassées de roses et
pictures un vaccin pour calmer les
angoisses
la flambée de cas de kobe 19 ans qui
était cette dame de 76 kg vs
l'élémentaire descendants des comptines
beaucoup elle se sent maintenant
rassurés
l'inde intensifie son opération aux
vaccinations qui accuse du retard 3
millions de patients sont inoculé chaque
jour dès la semaine prochaine toutes
personnes de 45 ans et plus pourra être
vacciné
l'objectif est d'avoir inoculé 300
millions de personnes d'ici le mois
d'août cette responsable d'une clinique
de vaccination espère que la population
ne traitera pas le vaccin comme une
pilule miracle et qu'elle restera
vigilante
un an jour pour jour après l'imposition
d'un confinement nationale dans ce sous
continent d'un milliard trois cents
millions d'habitants l'inde est
confrontée à la deuxième vague provoquée
par le relâchement des mesures
sanitaires est alimentée par le retard
dans la vaccination ici philippe leblanc
radio-canada délit